Who attributed or some people at least
are attributing that to Gingiss con
killing some somewhere in the neighborhood
of 10% of the population on Earth Dam.
One out of 10 he killed more people
than aids. Yeah, definitely. Right.
How many people did AIDS kill it?
If you had to guess
someone was just talking
about that recently and say,
no one should die from HIV anymore.
No one should die of AIDS.
It literally shouldn't have to
happen anymore. And that crazy.
This take medication now we were kids.
Everybody was terrified at aids.
AIDS was a death sentence
while eating Twinkies,
terrified of aids while eating
that thing that slowly killing you.
Terrified of getting some aids.
Chubby little kid gets it.
Everybody who doesn't want
to go to school no more.
Remember that one kid go to school.
Yeah, the magic God in there.
But they were though, right? Magic.
Got It. I remember being in my car.
I was in my car. I was living in
revere Massachusetts right here. Yeah.
This uh,
apartment complex and I was driving
my car and I was on the hot.
I was on the road listening
to the radio like you know,
you see where the traffic
lights are, you see, you see,
you remember it's like burned in your
brain. Like Ah, Magic Johnson has aids.
What in my car?
That's what I remember thinking like it
was a scene in a vampire movie monster
movie or something like a Zombie
outbreak. Like, oh my God, now it's,
it's reached one of the
greatest basketball players
of all time. This is insane.
Are people going to just start dropping
off like flies? Now I'm going to start.
We just thought we didn't condoms right
away afterwards. I don't think so.
We need,
you know,
animals bro Savage,
the savage.
I mean there's a reason why
there's 7 billion of us. We stop.
People need to stop pretending
that when they're, you know,
full fully aroused that they're
thinking straight like you,
you are operating at about like 10% of
your normal resources. I see. Like A's,
whatever.
Who's got aids?
He still got A's after they got
rid of it with a code. Well,
you know,
it's crazy that it was just primarily
gay people in drug users that we're
getting it. It's what a weird disease
man. That's a, that's a weird one. Men,
that's a strange thing that you're,
you're,
when your body starts weakening
and shutting down like Whoa.
But when you really think about
the actual danger and death,
like I think even while aids was
in its height of killing people,
I don't think it was killing people
as much as the flu was right.
The numbers I'm finding now or depending
on worldwide or u s so worldwide
tuberculosis is now killing
more people than aids. But uh,
this says that only 1.1 million people
today in the u s are living with aids.
And I think I saw,
but living with aids, it's like
you're at the border of getting aids.
Is that what it is? It's like, yeah,
you have h supposedly this and again,
I'm not a doctor, right? Supposedly
it's like you have HIV, your,
your immune system gets weakened.
You catch aids,
which is acquired immune
deficiency syndrome,
which means your t cell
levels have reached a certain
count where they identify
it as aids,
right?
Yeah. It actually did type in
aids and this is going to HIV. So,
so those that's,
they're definitely connected.
So it's not people that also their immune
system fails. That's outside of HIV.
Yeah. This, so I clicked on this,
I'll show what I clicked on it.
So I typed in that end, and
this is showing this, it
says at 1.2 million people,
I've received an aids diagnosis
since the early eighties
since the early eighties okay.
So 1 million people.
And there have been 12,000 in 2014 there
were 12,333 deaths due to any cause of
people with diagnosed HIV infection.
Ever classified as AIDS. And
hmm. What does that mean?
You had it then at 6,000 weird way
of saying it with people. Well,
I'll say it again.
It says there were 12,333 deaths due to
any cause of people with diagnosed HIV
infection.
Ever classified as AIDS.
Isn't that a strange way of saying that?
Yeah.
With the,
I don't know what that means.
You can lose it to the classification if
your immune system gets strong enough.
It says with diagnosed HIV
infection ever classified as AIDS.
Okay. Are the, I don't know,
maybe I'm too stupid for that because
what I also saw was that a million people
died last year from it, but that'd be
worldwide. And this then contradicts,
cause it says a million people have only
been diagnosed and this is only in the
US and that other numbers worldwide.
So it gets really sketchy. And it says
thousand 721 deaths were
attributed directly to HIV. Yeah.
So it seems that they, they definitely
think it's still killing people.
Definitely still is,
but yeah. But what is,
how many people die
from the flu every year?
What do you, what do you would you
think would be the most, the route,
most ruthless,
normal killer would be the flu.
The flu would kill the most people 36,000
way more way more people got jacked by
the flu every year,
every year.
And what was the number from the
aids number was total. Right.
How many of those people that flu shots
though? What is it? How many of those?
And then 2014 so it's a third or so.
So what's a third aids to the flu.
AIDS is about one third of the
deaths of the flu per year.
Ish on average.
I don't know
that.
Interesting.
It's like we're not scared of the
thing that kills us from way more.
We're really scared of the thing that
kills less people because it kills him
through butts. Eggs. That's what it is.
It has to be,
we're terrified that it kills people
through sex because like the flu,
it is like we should really be
concentrating on that thing.
That thing's killing way more people.
People not washing their hands,
but they're like, look, we can't stop
that, but we can stop off his buttocks.
Weird. Right. It's weird, like when we,
maybe it's just because it's a new
thing that was killing people because it
didn't exist and then it did exist.
That's probably what it is, right? Yeah.
Like yeah, because it came out of
nowhere because it was in like,
what was it during the 80s and the
Eddie Murphy is dead and you're walking
around with the A's on your lip.
Oh, was that, was that delirious?
Do you remember Sam kinisons bid
on it? He goes, they say, Sam,
you shouldn't make fun of AIDS aid.
Sam has a communicable disease.
Straight people can get it too.
He goes, name what name? Hey Fuck.
It's not our dads.
He had this crazy dangerous bit about
it and like way back then like whoa.
It's like a cro in around like 1980
I don't know if that's accurate,
but so 1980 was the highest peak in
thousands. So yeah, it seems like the low,
it seems like it seems
like late seventies right?
Is that somewhere around
1980 the one thing too,
I read that there's around 300,000 total
deaths and a third of them are in New
York,
300,000 total deaths,
a third in New York and the flu.
And this is all told ever.
Again,
the stats are all on multiple pages.
So here's how many of them I see.
I get so confused about all this shit
because some people believe that a lot of
these people also are shooting heroin.
A lot of these people were also doing a
lot of drugs. I would wonder, you know,
if they're really partying hard
and they also get aids, I would.
I would always wonder like how much of
you partying hard is destroying your
immune system too. Like if
you're, if you have a disease,
like say you have cancer
and you're struggling with
cancer and you just decided
to hardcore start smoking meth
and then you die from the cancer.
Like is it doesn't, didn't
something else kill you too. Right.
Not saying that the cancer is good
for you. Cancer certainly bad for you,
but if you have cancer and you just
decided to go on a meth binge and destroy
your immune system,
it's got to contribute to your health,
but we don't consider that.
We all consider up. They'll
fucking cancer. Got Him.
Cancer got him. It did get
him. It definitely did get him,
but he was also smoke and
math all day feeling good.
Doing robberies,
robberies with fucking skulls painted on.
It's getting more fights at
seven 11 yeah, man, he was amped.
Dude was amped with cancer.
That's, that's also,
I mean if he dies of a heart attack,
I all the cancer gave him a heart attack.
Yeah, probably that probably had something
to do with it. Definitely was not good.
It's definitely not good to have cancer,
but it's also not good to be smoking
math while you have cancer spoken. Beth,
that bat,
so how many of these people that got aids
were like extremely healthy folks that
like jogged on a regular basis and ate a
lot of fruit and vegetables are hard to
get that data. Yeah, I know.
I would like to get that data.
This is not like a prejudice perspective.
I'm just as a curious person,
I would like to get all that.
I would like to know what is it
that actually does it? Is it,
is it the math that kills you?
Is it a d a disease that kills you?
Is it a combination of all these things?
We always want to attribute
death to one thing,
but I would imagine that with all
the people that have died of the flu,
there's certain, there's a number of
deaths. We look at the flu. You're like,
man that the flu could just catch you.
The flu could just catch you and you know,
catch you when you're already week
two, maybe your, your rundown,
you've been working too much and then the
flu hits you when your immune system's
devastated and it gets deep into you
and gets you. I, everybody's vulnerable.
I mean the, the thing about diseases
that so strange to me, he said,
some of them are associated with certain
certain groups of people like aids.
Like AIDS is one of those ones.
It's just so associated with gay people
that it's like a really politically
charged disease and we concentrate
on it like really heavily.
But I think it, I really think it wasn't
just the gay thing was also that it was,
it was new, new, there was a new thing
that was killing people that day.
We were always worried about that.
Right.
There's always these pandemic movies
were some new crazy disease breaks loose,
just runs ramp and we don't
have an immune system for it.
People are start dying and they need to
get the medication to the people and get
it to the baby quickly. Ah, we
made people saw a subways, SARS,
just always some shit like that.
We're all SARS of some new shit that's
going to get us swine flu, chicken flu,
so that, well, so aids had a duel,
a disadvantage one that is connected
to gay people and people are like, oh,
what are they doing over there? What are
they not going to get it? I'm not gay.
Yeah, exactly. There was that and then
there was also, well blood transfusions,
car accidents. That's right. Right.
People were worried about
getting from blood transfusions,
so that means back then they were never,
they were like,
they were just letting random people
donate blood without checking it.
I don't think they had a
test for and for awhile.
I think for a while they didn't have a
task for it. Then they have to find like,
I guess they have to find like antibodies
in your blood or some shit and like,
Ooh, but it's so weird that
while this is all going on,
how many people were dying from cancer
every year just from smoking cigarettes?
It's fucking crazy numbers.
Crazy numbers.
People dropping like flies
and no one thinks about that.
When you see a guy smoking a cigarette,
you don't think that guys killing
themselves. You're like, God,
he's outside and for the restaurant and
having a cig normal shit. Now that guy's,
that guy's poisoning it himself
like a guy who the weak livers.
But it's just strange to me.
Like we get really specific about what
fears we have in terms of what way we
die.
And when a new disease comes along,
that becomes like one of
the most specific ones.
But while you're indulging
in all of these behaviors,
that will also kill you in way
larger numbers than diseases.
It's fucking weird, man. It's very
weird. But human beings, me included,
were so strange.